[Musique]
ah le fromage fondu verbaux nous sommes
dans la cour de josée robitaille
comme pour plusieurs d'entre nous depuis
l'enfance le number occupe une place de
choix dans ses menus d'été les brûlant
des pins ouest stone avec la galette la
boulette de viande hachée au cab la
madeleine et de sur le barbecue dans
comme mon père
cuisiner ça qui est un condiment steak
ketchup et moutarde early fromage jaune
orange en france c'est vraiment comme
ceux qu'on le mange et en amérique du
nord mais est maintenant tellement de
possibilités avec la parution de son
livre c'est l'été et la garder en tête
ce classique mais on lui trouve en
différentes variantes comme ce blogueur
de vaud j ajoute de l'échalote française
de l'ail de l'estragon du persil un peu
de moutarde à l'ancienne s'est bien
donné plein de saveur à la viande aussi
donc c'est intéressant peut acheter des
oignons hachés finement
les petits cornichons hacher finement
aussi des gens aussi que ça va être bon
il est déjà plein de saveurs puis le vol
avantage contrairement aux boeufs parce
que ce qui ne résout le goûte un peu
plus délicat mais ça peut traîner ça
avec du boeuf haché aussi alors on
chauffe la grippe qu'elle soit bien
chaude
on la ville et l'important c'est que
lorsqu'on tourne en galettes faut
vraiment que ce soit qu'on voit que ça
se décolle un petit peu son box à adder
expo prêtre tournée dont quatre ont qu à
feu moyen mais de bien huilé et de bien
chauffer c'est vraiment la base
garniture de mayonnaise au pesto de
tomates séchées quelques champignons et
des poivrons grillés
on peut aussi choisir d'autres viandes
pour varier les plaisirs
toutes les viandes bien sûr et veau
agneau cannor même allé dans du gibier
ça peut être intéressant et ensuite bon
poisson ça peut être intéressant aussi
avec du saumon
on pourrait aussi très bien toulousaine
d'armes on enlève les arrête et on met
une corde autour de la chaire de saumon
comme tel pour faire un genre de tourner
le dos de saumon le poisson blanc c'est
peut-être un peu moins intéressant c'est
moins creux et se défait un petit peu
plus ça va moins soutenir
rien ne nous empêche de voyager avec les
burgers pourquoi pas une version poulet
caries
donc on le sert dans un petit pain naan
auront leur ait acquis est un vieux
bourg à la menthe et concombres on est
vraiment dans les saveurs indiennes une
touche finale avec un chat n'est maison
aux courgettes et ses divers sont
enfermés à l'agneau avec un peu de bras
tatoués ou avec des poivrons du feutre
l'on n'est plus comme en grèce on pourra
voir du jet ski
j'aime ça allait chercher des saveurs
comme so les bangers vg ne sont pas en
reste dans la cuisine de josé je fais
aussi un avec portobello et fromages
doré milk est un fromage adoum québécois
sont aussi intéressants les champignons
portobello c'est assez merveilleux pour
le barbecue c'est un légume qui est
vraiment bien en deux dans ça remplace
très très bien oublié de viande hachée
par exemple premièrement j'enlève la
cuve puis ensuite c'est tout simplement
de le battre je n'ai avec de l'huile
d'olive puis c'est ça boit comme assez
le champignon c'est 90% d'eau aux
champignons fêtera ses cuisses a besoin
d'huile et j'ai un mélange des pistes
que je fais qui est un organe poivre et
fenouil
donc j'en ai un peu et bien sûr un peu
de sel aussi pour l'assaisonnement et
donc je fais sera coté quand je vais le
mettre sur le barbecue chez lui les
locaux tpiy salle et où son petit peu
l'autre côté deux champions en plus du
fromage à l'umih bien grillées elle
ajoute aux mathes pesto et une salade de
chou et fenouil maison simple comme
bonjour
une dernière variante végétarienne le
blogueur au tofu cela ne te fuis et dans
la marina depuis combien de temps je les
fais hier donc c'est bien le mener au
moins une journée ça peut aller jusqu'à
2 3 jours sans problème ça va prendre
encore plus de saveur sa marinade et
composé de mise au sirop d'érable ail
gingembre et huile de sésame vous lavez
coupez avant le mari oui exact à peu
près un demi pouce des pays en cas pas
faire avec une ligne vingt bons mètres
en jeu donc on en met deux par buggy
puis vous prenez tofu ferme à la barre
oui de fer - titre ferme parce qu'on
veut pas quelque chose qui s'égrènent
petit sienne bien la cuisson donc c'est
l'idéal pour saliver davantage la clé
est souvent dans l'ajout de condiments
l'a16 au noble cela est le secret du
chef je me relie chômage griller les
maïs sont sans griller sur le barbecue
ensuite sont cuits avec oignons poivrons
rouges vinaigre ce il ya un ketchup
heinz maison qu'on peut faire avec des
tomates
quand c'est le temps des tomates et les
tomates sont me c'est vraiment le temps
de faire sa une source tiny qui
accompagne mon blog out of us est
incroyable cette source elle est
vraiment vraiment très très bonne avec
gingembre de l'ail du tennis au derrab
peu de sonia lequel se goûte en premier
je sais pas sans tellement bourg pour
que je suis presque pas de départ celui
je pense qui m'étonne le plus c'est
peut-être le tofu j'ai envie de
découvrir parce qu'avec sa bulle et le
kraken assala pour seulement une belle
texture hambourg a pour leur gueule
tendre c'est tout fait en relation
toutes les sauces thaï niche souvent
mentionné le très bon goût en attaque le
portobello portovelo d'accord plus je
trouve vraiment inspirant différent
aussi avec la salade de chou d'un burger
c'est quelque chose qu'on freine c'est
certain mais j'trouve ça donne au rallye
des nations unies ouais ouais
hossa a répété à la messe
awek à salade de chou c'est vraiment bon
sous bon la version vos poumons
connaissait davantage
on sait déjà que ça va être bon sens oui
ça c'est sûr qu'un bon chénard phare qui
donne du goût le ps ou thomas séchet
coup est dur de plus que donc avec ça
c'est sûr qu'on passe à méditer
[Musique]